hey welcome to DLM model lifestyle
I'm Daniel Maritz and in this video we
are going to talk about 10 things that
women like about men and we are starting
right now
now if this is your first time on my
channel please subscribe so that you
won't miss anything
okay now let's start with number one
number one is good grooming and styling
women like it when a guy takes care of
himself now I get it not all guys are
into fashion but if you just do a little
bit of effort especially if you go out
with a woman it means a lot and good
grooming doesn't show self-importance it
shows self-respect
number two confidence a confident man
gives a woman a feeling of he will
take care of her whatever happens I know
it sounds strange but women do not like
fickle men they like men that they can
trust and that really shows that
confidence confidence is not just about
the way you're talking but it's the way
you carry yourself the way you handle
certain situations and being sure about
the actions and the decisions that you
make all right number three is sense of
humor yes ask any woman out there if she
likes a guy with a sense of humor and
she will say yes women just want to have
a really fun and happy life and so they
want to be with a guy that has a fun and
cheerful approach to life number four is
a good physique if you have a good
physique you just look a lot
healthier and clothes fit you a lot
better as well so you just stand out a
bit more and women like it number five
is a charming personality it's not just
about what you say but it's about how
you say it and it's not just about
talking but it's about really listening
and then how you respond to what you've
heard okay number six is a respected man
now we all know women like to be
respected but they also like it when a
man is respected by other people so your
name means a lot number seven is a
compatible personality women likes it
when a man has similar interests and
values that doesn't mean you have to
change who you are it just means that
you will attract the right person
alright number eight is security women
want to feel safe and they want a guy
that can provide them with security
I'm not talking just about physical
security I'm talking about emotional
security as well now that goes a lot
deeper number nine is passionate and
adventurous women love it when a guy
wants to do and see new things someone
that is not afraid of change and sitting
on your couch every weekend is not gonna
cut it so go out and enjoy life with a
woman and be passionate about it because
life is short number ten is trust every
woman likes a guy that they can trust if
they don't have that they will never be
happy okay just a bonus tip women likes
it when a guy can really share their
emotions that doesn't mean you have to
go out and just cry and be very
emotional it just means that you share
what you really feel all right if you
have any other tips please list it in
the comments below so that we can all
check it out if you liked the video give
it a thumbs up subscribe and that's it
cheers guys number five is a cheerming
cheerming...what is cheerming...lol  woman likes it when a
no bird physics fizzy fizzy things
women like
you